I'm going to do this from now and I'm
going to stop using the term mental
health I'm going to start using the term
mental Fitness because it speaks to a
process but it also speaks to good days
and bad days like when somebody is
engaged in their own physical fitness I
know when I'm starting to get fit it's
sometimes a little bit of a struggle but
I keep pushing through and I also know
when I'm physically fit that I'm
actually able to manage difficult things
more so I know that I can lift heavier
weight and I know that I can push myself
through pain I know that I can run a
longer distance because if I feel the
physical pain I know because I'm fit I'm
not going to actually damage my body
mental Fitness is the term because
mental health is actually doing us a
disservice so I think we're perpetuating
the disease state by calling it Mental
Health